walnut trees carpet these mountains from
Horizon to Horizon this ancient forest
has grown to cover a total of thirty
thousand hectares in southern Kyrgyzstan
one that's are the main source of income
for the people who live here the nuts
are primarily brought down by young men
who climbed the trees and shake them out
of the branches there's virtually no
alternative here the trees can grow to
40 metres in height so it's a risky and
occasionally fatal business but
effective cual Nick when I'm climbing I
always try to hold a branch in one hand
with the other on another branch
obviously the higher you go the more
dangerous it gets from getting with the
nuts on the ground the whole family
comes along to pick them up they've
least the rights to the harvest from the
state the woods are swarming with people
during the walnut harvest Yogi's are
traditionally a nomadic people furniture
is rare here everyone sleeps on mats on
the ground I work with my two sons and
daughter-in-law in a good year we get
two or three tons of walnuts but this
year we've barely made 300 kilos
nonetheless the markets of Jalalabad are
still full of nuts in the shell they
cost around 2 euros a kilo but without
the shell they'll bring six euros so
pace to crack them open during the
Soviet era the entire nut harvest had to
be turned over to the state these
farmers say that's something they don't
want to go back to ever again
here in the foothills of the seven
thousand meter high tian shan mountain
range the locals face a different set of
problems though the walnut forest used
to be really dense here but there's been
a lot of deforestation new trees
urgently need to be planted but grazing
herds effectively gobble up the next
generations trees it will take 30 years
for these seedlings to grow to maturity
if there wasn't a fence here the local
livestock would soon be along to graze
yep you can see that the other side is
completely barren look at how green and
beautiful this is as nomads people here
aren't very familiar with the concept of
fences but if they can't adapt to them
Jurgis walnut could easily become very
scarce